when i was fighting the ufc i would
never let the doctor ever use any
painkiller anytime he had to stitch me
closed because i wanted to feel that
pain because i made a mistake in there
in the octagon and i didn't want to dull
the pain because there should be a
consequence for that pain and i wanted
to remember that pain in the future
tim kennedy america you're [ __ ] here
i made it mine right do your thing
i'm here i did make it i'm pumped thank
you
what's happening just uh busy bee as
ever
um
getting ready for this book
and uh expanding freedom preserving
protecting human life uh
man just like the purpose of man i guess
i knew that you'd done a lot and then
reading the book it feels like you've
lived
maybe between four and five lifetimes to
fit everything in yeah my mom is
absolutely positive that
um
if like reincarnation is a real thing
i'm a cat and that i have died nine
times already and that i've broken the
cat nine life rule because clearly i
should have been dead more than nine
times already and i've lived at least
nine lives yes talk to me about what's
driven you through childhood to get to
where you are now the sort of person
that's in front of me yeah the
i'm dumb that's a big contributing a big
contributing factor is i'm dumb uh i'm
really stubborn
and i can't stop
and when you put those things together
you um you have this kind of relentless
pursuit
of
in my case it was a purpose and an idea
and like it didn't matter
as a young man without a fully developed
frontal lobe you know like making lots
of bad decisions i still kept moving
right uh even almost drowning uh when i
was i don't know trying to kill myself
or not but swimming out in the pacific
ocean a couple of miles just try to
like get another chance at life um
i just kept swimming you know getting
blown up in afghanistan just kept moving
um you know like pissing off my
teammates in iraq
being a young
ignorant
narcissist i just kept moving
so uh
yeah just kind of this adventure that is
life that's full of failure and
lots of struggles in my life i just kept
moving do you know where that comes from
is that something that's just in you is
that do you feel like that's heritage
i think a little nature and a little
nurture you know uh
my family
i'm surrounded by greatness you know my
grandpa came from the greatest
generation
you know world war ii
hero
you know literally dropped bombs on
nazis type guy and um
survive the great depression you know
the patriarch of our family and setting
everything up and then my dad a
heroic but
undercover narcotics officer my big
brother all my uncles vietnam war like
i'm surrounded by strong genetics yeah
just like some strong stuff
and then in the environment that i grew
up in
ordinary
was just not accepted like
playing average was just not
ever
an allowed state of being you know
it was uh high achievers and every
everywhere i looked and um
doing anything else besides the best
that you could do was just not enough
did you always know that you wanted to
be in the army yes
yeah yeah i was uh at north county
christian school
um the same school that
this jerk made fun of laura lakerie
because she had a
new haircut that looked kind of boyish
and shame on her mom for putting that
bowl on her head and then cutting her
hair but that's what happened
and um and he made fun of her and i
followed him up onto the playscape and i
punched him in his mouth and i pushed
him off which broke his arm and i got
paddled in the
ld i was four
yeah and um but in the same time period
we journaled like and i still have this
journal today it's like this little tiny
you know like has wallpaper
glued on the outside of it i'm not sure
if all kindergarteners or kindergarten
made their kindergartners do this but
inside of it it's like what do you want
to be when you grow up and like who is
your family what does your house look
like and you draw all these things
and what do i want to be when i grow up
is a picture of a camouflaged guy
jumping out of an airplane
and
a dude wearing a martial art ghee doing
karate you're kidding me i'm dead
serious
so there's a couple of things that are
happening here one
i very very early on knew right and
wrong and that i was going to stand up
to bullies and two
i kind of knew what i wanted to become
and uh the journey to become that was
long arduous meandering yeah
i got distracted lots of living yeah
before i finally but man i got penalized
every time i went astray you know like
so like
thinking i had aids that's that's a good
example of it knocking up a bunch of
women another great example of it that
was prior to the swim out to the ocean
right that's right that's right you know
uh
wrecking my motorcycle i'm not saying
that my my grandpa died of emphysema by
my choices but it felt like it you know
like every time that i wasn't doing what
i was put on this planet to do
i was
the the consequences of those bad
decisions like had serious repercussions
i've been thinking about this a lot
recently so radical responsibility you
know jocko's put this forward taking
complete responsibility for the things
that you do i do sometimes wonder if
there's such a thing as too much
responsibility where you take
responsibility for things that you don't
have responsibility for and it sounds
like maybe that creeps in yeah there
might be a little creep um
but
you absolutely the extreme ownership
jocko approach to this if you look at
all of the things that were going wrong
in my life almost all of them were my
doing like there were my choices and the
repercussions from those you know like i
go to an orgy with a bunch of girls
after a fight and one of the girls has
hiv and she walks into the gym he's like
hey i have hiv i was like cool this is
on me there's no other blame there right
yes uh wasn't somebody else's pain no
100 percent
my penis um you know like
putting babies and a few different women
at the same time like there's nobody
else no nobody else's penis in there
like that's mine
and uh you know like
failure at work um like indecisiveness
in school like all of those things were
those are my decisions and then
compounded by
you know as we deal with stress
external stressors you have coping
mechanisms and and those things are the
how you deal with all of these different
struggles well the really important ones
to me at the time
one of them my grandpa was dying in
front of me you know every breath was
just slightly less than the prior breath
so
you know my motorcycle i think that was
my it was me that crashed that you know
like i'm going down 90 miles an hour on
highway 46. like that's a that's a me
choice when that meth sure that meth had
pulled out you know like had i been
going 55 i could have been able to stop
um instead i you know
did not
so
i i definitely hear you but um
i'm gonna go ahead and accept ownership
for the vast majority of the problems in
that specific time period okay so then
when you do decide to
get into the armed forces you do decide
to join special forces
is that the beginning of a path where
you begin to take a little bit more
responsibility
i love how you're like putting in a lot
of um
the adjectives and pronouns in there
because i i was not yet like beginning
to absolutely i was beginning i was
starting this was like definitely not a
turn that
in the hero movie this is not like that
moment where there's like hero music not
the call to adventure yet yeah he's like
oh i mean he's gonna do the right thing
now that's not happening no he's gonna
continue to [ __ ] up for ages ages
episode five yeah like season 10 he
might start to get things a little bit a
little bit yeah that's how this that's
how that journey was so lots of
really shameful regretful moments with
lots of humbling experiences
okay so i've heard you talk about this a
good bit i've heard you talk about the
fact that sort of shame and reflecting
on um
deficiencies
situations where you didn't know enough
do enough have the capacity that that's
one of the driving forces for you yeah
but
for a lot of people when they have that
shame it it causes inertia
right it doesn't cause movement yeah
that's dumb
but you understand why that might happen
talk to me about that so if i like step
on a grill
and the grill is i don't know let's just
say how is the temperature of a grill
400 degrees 500 degrees too hot okay
it's hot right and i'm standing on that
grill and i'm burning
why would i stay there
like there's a beautiful purpose to pain
and a pain is a thing that moves us
emotional pain like you get cheated on
by your girlfriend and you're like ow
that really really hurt i'm gonna go
ahead and break up with this
relationship and i'm gonna look for
different characteristics in the next
partner cool got it i'm going to
um pick up this paper the wrong way and
it gave me a paper cut oh that really
hurt right like i'm going to pick up
paper differently to know that not to
get a paper cut the next time i'm not
going to slide my finger on the long
edge of the paper like so pain has this
really really important purpose and i
don't know why
people dull it people like intentionally
avoid it people deny that it ever
happened they
ignore these mistakes and they ignore
these failures they ignore these
struggles and they dis and then like 30
years later they're paying a few hundred
thousand dollars to talk to a counselor
to like work through these experiences
or or just hear me out
acknowledge that they're real and that
everybody has them
and move
and things get better
you don't burn alive on that grill you
don't cut your hand on paper you don't
get cheated on in the next relationship
and you slowly start having this
improved life
over just acknowledging that pain serves
a purpose and instead of doling it with
whatever pills you're popping or
whatever you're drinking or whatever
yoga class you're doing and they're all
all different ways to dull it
just be real and be present
and it's it's a shame in 2022 where
we curate and editorialize everything
about our lives and we hide our failures
and we use a new filter to to disguise
our blemishes on our face or the scars
and and
and lines around my eyes you know like
there's a lot of living here
i want to know it
when i was fighting the ufc
and uh in strike force i would never let
the doctor ever
use any painkiller anytime he had to
stitch me closed
didn't you get stitched closed by
some dude with a a cigarette in your
face yeah twine yeah yeah yeah that was
that was ufc um yeah i think it was
fishing line i'm pretty sure it was
fishing line he had a bone necklace
hanging from his his neck um that was at
an indian reservation
long before i caught on the floor and
yeah bits of rope around the bar and
stuff yeah
um but like this at strikeforce ifl wc
ufc you know like they had proper
doctors
and uh stitching us up and a matter of
fact the i think his hashtags like ufc
doc and he's he sews up everybody and he
tweets often about how uncomfortable he
was stitching me up because i would sit
there with my eyes open as he's as he's
closing my cheek
and he's like no i'm gonna give you a
local i'm like you give me a local i'm
just gonna walk out and i'm gonna be the
way that i am or you can stitch me up
and and he's like i never knew what to
do with this dude but then i just sit
there and tim wouldn't move and i'd sew
his face closed
because i wanted to feel that pain
because i made a mistake in there
in the octagon
and i didn't want
to dull the pain because there should be
a consequence for that pain
and i wanted to remember that pain in
the future
talk to me about the difference between
your first and your second deployment
when you went away because the first one
you were part of a team
and the second one you were very much
alone on your own yeah
give me a sense there because there's
kind of this romantic lone wolf like no
[ __ ] no support needed kind of thing
right that can be
put over the top of a character like you
yeah
what's it like that first time what's
the genesis of that and the reason i ask
this is there are a bunch of people
listening who think [ __ ] yes like i
want this i want to be a sovereign
individual with agency who goes after it
and gets after stuff in his life
but the first time that you go that
first
beginning of the rock moving up the hill
can be pretty uncomfortable and i wanted
to hear your sort of sensation around
that and it's supposed to be
uncomfortable
you know the uh the special forces oda
the operational detachment alpha which
is like the 12-man a-team right like the
tv show the a team like it's it's it's
the collective
of
all of the best and the brightest put
into a team the [ __ ] of the
[ __ ] that's right and dude and
they are hammers like i walk down halls
of heroes and these guys are giants to
my left and to my right both emotionally
physically mentally like they're just
the most incredible humans on the planet
and um
and i'm the weakest link
you know i am the newest i'm the weakest
i'm the slowest
um
i'm the fastest to judgment um i'm the
quickest to anger i'm all of the things
that i shouldn't be
and the refiners process
like on on my war table up there if we
started playing with all of the
instruments of violence all of them were
forged in a really similar way in a
really violent way you know they they
took a clump of something they heated it
and they pounded the impurities out of
it and that's what a team does
you know like i showed up as a lump of
uselessness
and through time through grace through
forgiveness through suffer suffering
through
i mean i guess now
they uh they call it hazing but like
that's part of the process
that um that shape expedited learning
yeah and it is so important
so important so that first team
that first deployment i'm surrounded by
the best and the brightest
and i'm
learning painfully what it means to be a
team member
thank god for that because i would be
dead
in afghanistan many times over so many
times had they just not shaped
who i was how i'd respond how i would
think how i would speak
not just capability and lethality but
also survivability durability
and then you go off on your own
yeah
yeah
not by design i was supposed to go over
as a sniper team but um my teammate
my sniper teammate had uh
so in the military there's this like
ever existing joke about the girl that
cheats on the guy while he's deployed
and we actually have a name for her
and um so that's what happened to him he
deployed and his what's her name
jody jo oh
i've heard that in movies yeah it's yeah
it's pretty it's pretty there
so like every time joby or yeah jody or
joby
um every time that that soldier goes
away she's looking for the next
convenient
guy
and that you know it was all pretty
strategic for
for him
and for her
so when he left
she drained his bank account and
um you know filed for divorce and sold
all of his stuff so
you know he's in war and in crisis mode
and thank god special forces for once
they never do this like actually cared
about the soldier and they're like
there's no way he could have been combat
effective right like world war ii it's
like sorry bro you're already in europe
like
enjoy the beach hopefully you can make
it up it or you're dead
um this was
this was really cool of the army to
bring him back and let him recover his
life a little bit so it wasn't so
catastrophic
yeah but for you
yeah what about you yeah so for me it
left me with nobody dick in hand yeah
just looking with a big smile and being
like
what can i get myself into what kind of
trouble can i find
and uh i don't know if the stars had
aligned if uh if fate is real
but
i ended up being
assigned to uh the coalition which is
like this group of special operations
and i was put directly under one
sergeant major who is like kind of
directly in charge of me and he was the
liaison for all of these special
operations units so every time like the
british or
the
cansoff or the australian soft any time
those guys would be stepping out the
door uh you know there was a use of sock
level one special forces sniper that was
happily ready to be both a liaison a
reconnaissance or a snapper
sniper asset for those teams
so it's like my wet dream totally coming
true i got to go work with like the
coolest international forces on the
planet and it's like me you know like
it's just me
it was cool
until it's not cool
when uh you know it's cool when
everything's going right and you're
kicking ass
and uh and then
it's super not cool when you don't
really have a team
the
bomb goes off id explodes vehicle in
front of you just vaporizes killing
almost everybody inside of it and ending
up on top of your hood and this is like
the beginning of a multi-day gun fight
you know and i'm
i mean i'm i'm with some americans but
i'm mostly with the czech special forces
and
and like i don't have my own team you
know like
um
like nobody put me in for a purple heart
because there's nobody to write a reward
for me like i don't have a captain you
know there's nobody to put me in for
anything because like there was no team
there's nobody like thank god i had
friends and brotherhood because mike
keller saved my life mike irish saved my
life in this particular oh yeah battle
yeah my goal saved my life i mean one
instance i had like divine intervention
this way you run out of ammo
oh yeah that happens that's running
within like 20 minutes oh yeah
yeah
like you when you think that like a
special forces detachment could run out
of value like how is this possible like
be surrounded by 400 iranian freedom
fighters um foreign fighters and uh
they're not fighting for freedom they're
fighting for enslavement i don't mean
that word freedom people call them
freedom fighters but they're really like
what's the opposite of freedom
i don't know that's the type of fighters
they are okay so insert that word the
antithesis of freedom yes pricks anyways
so they're kicking our ass i'm like
crawling on the ground eventually trying
to find ammo but mike keller
when the vehicle in front of me explodes
and uh like you know pink mist
everywhere
humvee lands on top of my humvee my
humvee starts backing out to get away
from this humvee as like rpgs are sc
like skipping off of my hood and rounds
are like ping ping ping ping ping and
the side of this humvee is pkm rounds
are just like
mike keller gets up to the side of this
hill mike irish who is driving he's like
oh my god those guys are still alive so
he like hops out of the vehicle
mike where are you going so he runs back
down to where we just got blown up so i
hop out of the vehicle very begrudgingly
i did not want to go with him and i was
really mad that he just was being heroic
and he runs down there and we get down
there i'm carrying my sniper rifle at
this time i have an sr-25 sniper rifle
with a suppressor on the end of it
and uh we're trying to pull these bodies
out from underneath this overturned
humvee
when the assault line of the taliban run
across the the ambush zone which we call
the x like the kill zone
and all this taliban or they're like 10
feet from me 10 feet and i'm trying to
move my sniper rifle as i'm holding this
half cut off body that's dripping bile
and crap and blood all over me
and uh and then i'm sure i'm concussed
at this moment but the thing that really
gives me the real concussion
is mike keller in the 50 calim2 machine
gun
turret position
this is god like i don't care what you
believe there's only one way that you
can describe how mike was able to use a
machine gun with a 50 caliber machine
gun and shoot rounds around mike and i
and vaporize this assault line they just
like there were people there this isn't
like movie like rambo and they're like
you see guts flying through there it was
like there were there were there were
people right here and then there were no
more people like they just disappeared
not like pink mist and like an hbo movie
where like a sniper takes a shot i mean
they were just like there and then they
weren't and that was mike shooting 50
cal rounds like zipping them up and
around
weaving them between wheels through them
yes wild
wild
so we drag these soon to be dead bodies
up and um we try to save them for a
while
they ultimately die we get a few ammo
resupplies we have ac-130 gunships f-15s
f-18s f-16s apache helicopters like when
you um actually i think they made a
movie called broken arrow
they did right
yeah
like broken arrow is a term where if you
are a ground force commander and you say
broken arrow this like goes all the way
back to the like the colonel custer days
where he got surrounded and if you don't
send every single resource that you have
available right now
we're all going to die
that that's what that term means okay
that's the hail mary call of all hail
mary that is like if there is a plane in
the air it comes to me if there's a
helicopter that has enough gas to come
here and has one bullet left it will
force a guy with a hammer bring him yes
yeah cool you got a screwdriver i'll
take you you're on yeah that that is
that is what this call means so when
they called um
broken arrow it's like we're all gonna
die every single one of us is not gonna
make it out of this valley and uh so
then like
it changed slowly
from
all of us maybe dying probably dying to
everyone around us dying and us still
thinking we're going to die
which leads me to then mike goble
i'm walking up to a door where i think
we're three days into this gunfight i
still haven't slept i still have a
concussion i have like black i have
hours of of this gun fight that i don't
remember
um i have moments where like we crest a
hill and i find the support um camp for
the taliban and there's like a bunch of
taliban in front of us i'm so i'm now
somehow in a check vehicle like i'm with
the czech special forces like i left
these kind of sounds a little bit to me
like some of the after parties that i've
been back to like this is the same
discordant story
of like and then before i knew i'm in
this villa and then i'm on a golf course
i have no idea how i got here no clue
yeah okay the brain's wild yes yes yeah
especially when it's like
damaged yes you know
and uh
i'm walking up to a door
and we just got shot at from this
compound and mike goebbel
it felt like he hit me he shoved me so
hard
both hands like like a rugby slam
double leg jon jones takedown you like
insert the most athletic movement you
can most violent he shoves me in front
of this door and we kind of split apart
as his energy pushes me back the energy
of him pushing me back pushes him back
and then the door disintegrates
as machine gun rounds just
trace through here and splinter this
door
i never heard a bolt drop
i never heard a weapon go from safe to
fire
there's no way that he heard it
because when you when we finally get in
this door we find the machine gun nest
it's about 20 meters back inside this
compound so there's no
explanation to how mike knew that this
door was about to get disintegrated did
you ask him uh he's dead now
did you get to ask him before he was
dead no we fought we got in a fist fight
like two days later
yeah best of friends best of friends
all right so
these sort of situations yeah
does that make
stepping into the octagon
to punch somebody else in the face under
a relatively now restrictive rule set
with a guy in there whose job it is to
make sure that if anything
close to serious happens that everything
stops
does that make that seem a bit like
and not silly or farcical but kind of i
mean yeah yes and no like i would walk
into the octagon over overly relaxed
and do you think that that was
contributed to by your time yes yeah
like leo korolinski when i was fighting
for the ifl
i remember the first time that he ever
saw me fight he's like
what is wrong with you
like you need to be excited yeah like
you need to be you need to be excited or
like nervous like what are you doing i
was like leo it's fine bro just like go
sit down i'm gonna go fight in a minute
he's like you are gonna go fight in a
minute can you like recognize that
you're about to go fight is it yeah yeah
go out and knock the guy out in the
first round
leo can you be cool now so it took like
10 fights for leo to realize that like
but
everything's even in fighting
you know so while i would walk in so
um
relaxed you know not stressed
the weight class is very specific you
know your opponent is picked so that you
guys have a competitive fight because
nobody wants to watch you know like
mike tyson fights a you know a prime
mike tyson fights a
43 year old fat white dude that came off
the couch like that's not interesting
they want to see like two
apex predator peak athletes
go head to head you know gorilla versus
bear you know lion versus polar bear
like that's what we're looking for
so
either even the referee like his
purpose yet there is to make sure that
we
not just
are safe but that we also fight under
the constrictions and the limitations
that are the rule set
which um which makes it very competitive
especially when you start getting up to
title fights and you know like i spent
the last 10 years of my career ranked
top 10 in the world
it's like i'm only ta i'm only fighting
top 10 guys you know like the michael
bispings and the robbie lawlers and the
jacares
um
and that
you know
that's hard i think there's no that's
hard
what's the difference between training
for fighting
and training for violence
training for combat violence there's no
difference
no they're um training in his training i
mean have you used uh bjj in a combat
situation
yeah
yeah i uh in iraq uh kind of humiliating
story so i'm not gonna tell all of it
i'll just give you the high points um
we do a call out we go to a bomb maker's
house and we tell everybody to come out
this is not in the book
and um
almost everybody comes out
but one guy stays in there and and we
asked the family
who is this and why is he in there and
they're like he's crazy
the language barrier it was difficult to
determine if he was like jihad crazy or
if he was like special needs crazy
we later find out that he was the latter
and um so when i go in there with my
team and we do a direct action like hard
knock assault you know like flash bangs
like this guy as i as i turn the corner
i'm the number two guy number one guy
goes right i went left there's a
center-fed room and this guy was like
and he like came i butt stroke him
breaking every bone in his face and then
like he grabs on to me as he's falling
and in my mind he's like grabbing all of
my stuff on my kit right like i got a
knife here i got my pistol here i have
uh some flash bangs i got my grenades
back here so i kamora i grab his arm i
grab his wrist i reached over his arm i
come on and i break every bone in his in
his shoulder his arm like everything is
like turned to dust and powder
but the kimura is a jujitsu move and i
just did it in in violent war settings
and like it is a very great technique
to do in competition but like it works
just fine kimura is also the the best
technique for weapon retention like we
use goose necks and finger flexes to uh
wrist locks to get weapons and knives
out of people's hands we use the
americana when we're in mountain
position we use neon belly to give me a
chance to like look around and make sure
it's like yeah it's a lot of
similarities
and the brain
and the body are shaped in the same way
like training is training
and the reason that you see so many
high-level athletes in special
operations that are coming from really
really violent type sports you see lots
of wrestlers you see lots of water
water polo players you see lots of rugby
lots of football
they're coming from environments that
training like this is really normal
so when they go to special forces
selection or they go to the queue course
they're like
yeah
yeah they've been here before yeah i've
been here before
everyone else is like what is going on
like i've never my feet have never felt
like this like then i did two days in
texas during football camp this isn't
this isn't anything
you're spinning a lot of plates are you
headmaster of a school now
sheepdog responds head mistress don't
pronounce me wrong sorry i used to
identify yeah now identifies this head
mystery and the headmistress of the
school there's someone listening to this
that thinks
this sounds [ __ ] dope like i'm
motivated i want to be this person i
want to have control over my life i'm
going to set my alarm for 6am i'm going
to find a bj jack you're pretty close to
me i'm going to do all of this at 5 30.
sorry 4 30 if you jocko yeah um that's
too early yeah yeah he's got it wrong
that's just too much um
there's someone that's out that that's
thinking that's what they want to do but
when the alarm goes off tomorrow morning
they're going to hit snooze yeah so what
is it that's causing you to not hit
snooze
but you can't relegate it to a single
decision like that you know there
i've made like millions of decisions
leading up to like i went to bed on time
you know like
i had an amazing and intimate night with
my wife you know like she fell over
sweaty and smiling i went and hopped in
the shower came back in bed and like i'm
gonna sleep hard right like not like
figuratively not literally yes you know
like
perfect long day of work had two great
workouts super productive got to spend
time with my family had a fantastic meal
all of those little decisions
led
to that alarm going off at 5 30 and me
popping up and be like nice and it's
playing uh
let's see this morning was uh
life on mars that was my alarm this
morning and uh it's rad you know it's
like boom and i'm up loving this song
ready to go after the day but i wasn't
ready
for that alarm
by it going off i was ready by like
thousands of other things that i did
before that
so
like you can't
narrow it to a single moment you have to
look at the millions of other
opportunities that you had to make the
right decisions
and that trend all of those collectively
will start making a difference we'll
start mattering it's about speeding up
and slowing down i think that if
momentum is taking you toward a
sub-optimal place a bad place
maybe all of your effort simply needs to
go into slowing that momentum down for a
little while and you it would be great
if you could go and hit every workout
and hit do all of these things but
you've probably got some bad habits that
you could do with deprogramming first
before you try to add some of the new
good ones in and that's going to happen
step by step by step well this goes back
to what we were talking about at the
very beginning about like how do you
know that those bad habits are
are putting your trajectory
negative because you reflect and it
hurts yeah you feel the the pain
that's right because you remember the
pain well they say that true hell is
when the person that you are meets the
person you could have been yeah may not
be terrible you feel
the delta between
where that person is and where you are
so something that i've considered
you've got this very heroic story the
book's fantastic
lots of different things that you've
done and achieved and you know during
the 15 minutes that i was late here
you've built a new gun and and and
[ __ ] organized a bunch of other stuff
for your school and other things like
that
what i'm always interested in is the
price that people pay to be themselves
especially high achievers what's the
price that you pay to beat tim kennedy
bad knees my knees are trashed
um
the uh
emotional baggage like i watch like a
um
i was watching the movie the searchers
with john wayne not saying dude you need
to watch this movie good yeah it's old
it's it's old and it's raw and it's
primal
story john wayne um
frontier texas new mexico arizona type
and um
their homesteaders
building their existence carving in
comanche apache land
and um
they see a fire in a in a a smoke trail
in a nearby
kind of near about a day's ride and so
they they head out to check it out
and it was a lure to bring john wayne
away from his brother's house
where his nephew his niece and
his sister-in-law were all there
the indians come in they kill everybody
they kill his brother they kill his wife
they they kill his nephew
and they steal this little girl
and john wayne comes back to find their
raped
bodies and burnt
male bodies and like this is early this
is 60s and his missing niece
so the movie the searchers is he then
goes this whole entire movie it's about
20 years this movie goes on where he's
searching for this that's about 15 years
this little girl
and he is a racist violent man he fought
for the confederate army now like every
engine red blood
half breed you can like you could just
see the chip on his shoulder and you
don't know by the end of this movie what
he's gonna actually do when he finds
this little girl like is he gonna kill
her like she is now an indian she's been
with them for 15 years
and as he's like running down or he's
he's on this horseback chasing this
little girl as she's running away from
him out of fear of this white man and
he's trying to rescue this little girl i
am bawling my eyes out
in like
relating to so many things like having
been to so many places and having so
many cultural questions of like what is
right what is wrong like what is right
for him should he have killed all these
people after they killed his family like
is that right is that justice is that
vigilante justice is this like where's
the justice here and like what is
supposed to happen to this girl and and
all these questions so
the the price is
bad knees so scars and stripes the name
of the book
uh
like there's lots of scars on the
outside clearly as you look at my face
you know my ears and like my orbital
sockets my hands my knees
um you know and then there's scars on
the inside there's plenty of them and
stripes in the military are
symbols
of you having experienced things
like your number of deployments your
time overseas how long you've been in
the military like what rank you are all
of those things are are testaments to
who you are so like what what is the
cost to be me like there is a lot of
pain
talking about scars and stripes what's
your favorite scar and what's your
favorite stripe
um
favorite scar is probably this one right
here robbie lawler
and uh he threw an uppercut he's a
southpaw my head was on the center as i
was doing a double leg against the cage
we drilled in training
my head position probably a hundred
times
and uh
in the fight
i thought i was faster i thought i was
better and uh he blasted me with this
uppercut
just like we knew he would in the exact
same way that we had game planned him to
do it
and uh so i carry that scar in
i prepared properly i trained correctly
i had all of the knowledge and and and
resources to be able to not have this
scar
but then i went on to brutalize him for
15 minutes and ultimately it win a
pretty
big big fight over you know ufc
welterweight champion
um
but like so i wear this chunky scar on
my nose with with pride
and then um
i think a lot of people would talk about
their rank or they talk about their
combat stripes
um
in special operations where like when
you go through that book when we went
through the legal review
most of the names in this book are dead
now
and uh
most of my friends like
literally most of my friends my sniper
partner sniper school dead sniper
partner deployment dead mike goble dead
you like you when you go through the
legal review the woman that did it the
lawyer was like she started crying about
10 10 names in i was like just wait till
memorial day like imagine how i feel you
know
so
the stripes of me still just being here
of uh which are your years in service
i'm proud of those because like
like the song rooster you know you can't
kill me yet
what's it feel like to reflect on the
fact that so many people that you
admired so much that helped you become
the person you are now
aren't here to see the person that you
are now
and ironically the ones that are here
are the ones that just want to see me
fail so it's kind of wild but um
not strange isn't it
yeah i wonder if that's selection
somehow i wonder if the ones what is it
i think about you die the hero or live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain yeah think about it all the time
it's like why is this one like that one
that one why is that one still alive and
that one's dead
you know like
yeah it's wild
you go down that why
if that what if why question man that is
a dark hole
yeah
be the bottom of the bottle on that one
but that's one of the motivations for
you right you say you don't want to feel
helpless you don't want to feel like you
don't know there's that story about i
think you're an emt when you were 18 or
something and you
you were trying to fix some girl and
then the guy came over that knew what he
was supposed to do and said
you need to find somebody else yeah i
got this yeah i got this yeah tom way
tom way i love you uh is he still about
he's still about good man yeah we got we
got one yeah there's one yes um
and uh
yeah that that that frustration of
not knowing what to do and that
helplessness is something that like like
that is a pain that
like you'll carry forever and that is a
shame that's a humiliation of like
standing there like i don't know what to
do like had i trained had i prepared um
had i made more of those right decisions
i wouldn't be standing here i would
already be taking action and saving
somebody's life but instead out of
whatever selfish decisions i made prior
i don't know what to do and now this
person might die
so yeah it's a big motivator what can
you tell us about what you're doing next
that's tricky when does this podcast
come out
no when do you want it to come out well
uh if we do it in like two weeks then i
can say that i'm going to eastern europe
okay
tomorrow and that i will be going to
work with save our allies
in a humanitarian
assistance
type role
to help uh is this part of your ngo
mm-hmm yep yep yeah save our allies is a
non-profit non-government organization
that goes to contested areas to see
lilly putting these people out yep cool
some of them
yeah i don't know if like finland
romania poland and hungary count as lily
pads because they're kind of just
neighbors yeah yeah but it works cool
man tim kennedy ladies and gentlemen uh
dude i love what you do i'm very very
happy that i'm in the same city as you
i'm looking forward to connecting
hopefully after this as well for sure uh
good luck man stay safe i think we need
more people like you thanks for the chat
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you